le voici donc un autre mouvement de
grève pointe à l'horizon
un mot d'ordre des pilotes d'air france
pour un arrêt de travail le 10 janvier
but de la grève
une revendication qui sera l'accrochage
de notre dossier en fin de journal sur
air france la fermeture de certaines
lignes de la compagnie
le syndicat national des pilotes de
ligne le syndicat national des officiers
mécanicien navigant d'air france ont
décidé d'une grève de 24 heures le lundi
10 janvier pour s'opposer à la politique
de récession décidée par la direction
d'air france tous les vols air france au
départ de paris seront touchés par la
grève les vols en cours seront
poursuivis jusqu'à destination